and now to our other top story here at
five o'clock talk about a field of
dreams we are getting our first look
today at what the potential new A's
ballpark will look like we thank you for
joining us I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftis specifics of how it will be
paid for however still remain unclear a
news now reporter Ryan Matthey joining
us live right near the Tropicana hotel
right now the desired location Ryan has
those specifics and what they could be
yeah Brian Denise we called the Nevada
legislature a game at this point
awaiting more solid Bill language it
would outline how this hotel behind me
here would be converted into a 1.5
billion dollar ballpark but the new
renderings they're a home run that
leaves both excitement and questions
a swing and a hit and it is glorious
Nevada senator Scott Hammond's reaction
to the Oakland A's first look of a
potential Las Vegas ballpark
situated at a busy strip intersection on
nine acres listed at a capacity of 30
000 Spectators with a partially
retractable roof to view the Las Vegas
Skyline however the Major League
Baseball rule book says stadiums should
face East Northeast and these renderings
seemingly show it facing Northwest
and the cost 1.5 billion but who pays
that you frequent that area if you go in
there and you patronize uh or uh the
baseball team then that's what's going
to go towards paying for it so it really
won't affect most of the taxpayers
senator Hammond telling eight news now
on Wednesday that the bill outlining
finances could be introduced this
weekend he says 180 million dollars in
transferable tax credits from the state
and another 120 million in Clark County
bonds that's 300 million in Public
Funding altogether a sharp decrease from
the original ask of 500 million but the
hidden question when will legislators
see a bill making this a reality if
there's a hearing on Saturday we need to
have the bill at least 24 hours before
we have the hearing I don't even know
where the bill will be presented whether
it's going to be the Senate first or the
assembly
now in terms of getting Clark County
government reaction the renderings come
at a pretty coincidental time the
commissioner's office is closed on
Friday's meeting we likely won't hear
from any of those officials until after
the holiday weekend reporting live
outside the Tropicana Hotel Ryan Matthey
a news now
now Hammond also notes that the
specifics he described those could
change so he says he's going to know
what lawmakers are asking for when the
bill is actually presented he adds it's
likely the A's will be responsible for
all costs that actually go beyond the
1.5 billion dollar budget